we're hearing from survivors of last
month's deadly siege in mozambique
by terrorists linked to isis this video
was taken by the son of a south african
contractor who found himself pinned down
with his father and his brother
in the town of palma the assault lasted
more than a week and left dozens dead
isis has spread its influence to
countries like mozambique
after losing most of the territory it
controlled in syria
and iraq only on cbs this morning
deborah pata spoke
to the men behind the video you just saw
outgunned outmanned overwhelmed the
mozambican army proved
no match for isis fighters as the
insurgents laid siege to palmer
building contractors greg knox and his
two sons adrian and wesley nels
sought refuge with colleagues in this
hotel
whenever the fighting grew closer they
would bunker down in the hotel bar
they were shooting at us over the wall
so we all
lying on the floor and just keeping our
head heads down
the festering insurgency began three
years ago but has escalated dramatically
in recent months
at stake a 50 billion dollar gas project
being developed by french american
and other companies
by day three isis insurgents encircled
the hotel
rescue choppers overheaded run out of
fuel and had to turn back
those inside faced a terrifying choice
wait to be rescued or make a run for it
we uh knew that by friday night we
weren't gonna
we won't survive another night there
they were going to get in
um and if they get in then it would be
we'd be slaughtered if the helicopters
are going then we must go it
they decided to leave in a 17-car convoy
adrian got in behind the wheel to drive
with a loving warning from his brother
it's going to be the driver of your life
bro it was here that wesley stopped
filming
within minutes of driving off they came
under fire adrian took a bullet in his
shoulder and leg
but kept on driving eventually
sorry eventually the car
came to a stop and i jumped out the back
seat
to the front and uh lifted him up and
pushed him to the back
um where my dad was holding him and
holding
his wounds to stop the blood by the time
they reached a safer place
it was too late cover them up
and uh
say say goodbye to that thank you for
saving all of our lives
and um we we then
left him in the car and we ran into the
bush
and we then had in the bush and thick
undergrowth for
two days eventually the longed for help
arrived and they were able to fly home
to adrian's family
bringing with them the body of a beloved
son and brother
and the heartbreaking images of his
final days
love you bro love you my man
a u.s state department official tells us
that the battlefield tactics used in
mozambique
are similar to those in iraq and syria
experts fear
it's a land grab by isis giving the
terror group a new launching pad for
attacks on the west
anthony what a heartbreaking story for
that family deborah pata in johannesburg
thank you
very much anthony was one thing after
another as we're watching it did he live
did he live then you hear he didn't and
then you get to see his final
words and his brother saying it's going
to be the ride of your life
to thank your brother and then to have
to leave him there oh that was tough on
the haunting video on your phone too
that lives forever